la confusión impera en europa cuando se
nombra la vacuna de astrazéneca la
gestión de vacunarse o vascular no de
astrazéneca pues es una cosa que no se
entiende porque en el día de hoy en
alemania ya están prohibiendo vacunar
con nuestra séneca a personas que hoy
están llamadas aquí primero el fármaco
de la universidad de oxford y el
laboratorio sueco se limitó a gente
joven ya que parecía ser más efectiva
pero este martes alemania encontró una
treintena de casos de trombosis después
de la vacunación con astrazéneca una
dolencia de la que advirtió dinamarca a
mediados de marzo y que parece afectar a
adultos jóvenes leo el diario cada día
veo las noticias y leo en internet te
vuelves loco intentando entender qué
está bien y qué está mal nadie lo sabe
así que tengo que confiar en los que sí
que saben
y es que cada país toma decisiones
distintas al respecto de astrazéneca un
fármaco que ya ha provocado varios
retrasos en las campañas de vacunación
estatales 7 países como alemania francia
o españa restringen la aplicación de esa
vacuna por edad en dinamarca y noruega
sigue suspendida hasta mediados de abril
a la espera de más estudios otros países
en cambio optan por usar astrazéneca con
normalidad como italia o reino unido-
mientras que las autoridades sanitarias
europeas tratan de restablecer la
confianza en el fármaco